sur cette photo stellan est encore qu'un
petit garçon mais pense déjà à changer
d'identité
c'était là ne veut plus être un garçon
elle se livre d'abord à sa maman avec
appréhension
j'avais peur comme on dit beaucoup et je
me suis dit allez il faut que je me
lance
parce que c'est une dizaine à une région
dire je me sens pas bien dans un choeur
de garçons et je me suis dit jusqu'à la
fin comme ça on ne sent pas bien et oui
j'étais sûr coloniaux winch au moins un
témoin qui a pris alors ce qui est
encore plus bouleversant celle écoute de
sa maman qui en fait est là soutien de
bout en bout de là à l'aide
et regardez cette relation qui a parce
qu'elle est petite dès mi temps quand
même
dès 8 ans regardez je suis encore venir
que d'un garçon puisque la version gt
malaise savait que qui savait qu'il
avait commis une erreur la planète la
nature toi tu as pu arranger ça du coup
moi j'ai pu arranger non maman a pu
arranger ça parce que y'en a ils veulent
pas comme heures car si par exemple
deviennent un garçon donc on la regarde
toi tu as eu la chance d'être depuis
qu'elle s'est trouvée et qu'elle peut
vraiment se vêtir comme elles a envie
c'est la joie c'est plein de couleurs
c'est vraiment c'est une enfant qui
renaît pour moi c'est ça c'est une
deuxième naissance et je découvre ma
fille comme je l'avais jamais vu avant
fait juste pour dire que c'était un
témoignage essentiel à montrer et
surtout ce que je voulais dire c'est que
dans de nombreux cas d'habitude les
parents sont un peu réfractaires à ce
changement de sexe et là c'est vrai que
la première des libertés en soit c'est
de pouvoir c'est le pouvoir
voilà posséder son corps entièrement et
voilà donc moi je dis bravo à nos
parents qui l'ont accompagné de bout en
bout à la sté essentiellement plus
surtout qu'elle est toute petite elle
est toute petite
alors je n'ai reçu de lait coûte